17th century jewish philosopher baruch
spinozza was excommunicated for heresy
at the age of 23.
rebecca goldstein writes about his
impact on jewish identity in betraying
spinoza
this talk from the jewish community
center in washington dc is just over an
hour
we are honored to have with us this
afternoon rebecca goldstein
a novelist of big ideas and a
philosopher with a writer's pen
rebecca is the author of several weighty
novels among them the mind body problem
mazel and properties of light
more recently she authored
incompleteness the proof and paradox of
kurt godel
she has received many awards for her
work including two whiting awards a
national jewish book honor and a
macarthur foundation fellowship
she is well known for her rigorous mind
and her attention to the humanity behind
exacting thinkers
her book on spinoza exhibits just that
please join me in welcoming rebecca
goldstein
[Applause]
thank you so much aaron
he's going to stay
all right
and thank you all for coming so much
excitement about a dead philosopher
i want to talk to you today about a
certain philosophical extremist
this is a man who made every claim for
the life of the mind that's ever been
made
he argued that the consolations of that
life the consolations of philosophy
are so potent that they can that they
should
take the place of the consolations of
religion
at least of religions as their
conventionally
understood and practiced
he tended to call these uh the
superstitious religions
quite obviously he didn't think much of
conventional religion
and conventional religion return the
favor
i'm going to hold off you might have
noticed saying his name for the time
being though you obviously know it
dealing with him in a detached and
impersonal manner suits him
he happens to be philosophy's strongest
advocate for impersonal detachment
for viewing oneself from a stance of
such radical objectivity that one almost
loses the sense of who one is
this is his idea of salvation
this philosopher takes the most extreme
stance that it's possible to take in
regard to a cluster of interlocking
philosophical questions
the first one is this
in some sense for this philosopher it's
the only question
because he believes he argues that
everything else that he says follows
from the answer that he gives to this
one question
here it is
does every fact in the world have a
reason that explains why it's a fact
is there always an explanation
or does there exist some degree of just
brute factuality
at either a superficial level what i
happen to put on today some trifling
arbitrary factoid or
at a profound level
deep down in the bowels of the
fundamental laws of nature
is there at any level at all
facts which are facts
for no other reason
than that they are facts
this philosopher
answers no
all facts have explanations for every
fact that's true there's a reason for
why it's true
there simply can't be the inexplicably
given
a fact which is a fact for no other
reason than that it's a fact
in other words no dangling threads
protruding from the fabric of the world
this intuition which can be called the
presumption of reason
that's what i call it and which various
famous physicists have also expressed
is the fundamental intuition for this
philosopher
from it he sets out to deduce the entire
nature of reality
and even more
he treats the presumption of reason as
on a par with the laws of logic
as a rule of inference that he avails
himself of in the course of deriving the
far reaches of his system
because this philosopher believed that
his presumption of reason was itself
logically true
he happened to have been wrong about
this it isn't
but because he believed it was logically
true and because he also believed that
everything else that he said about the
nature of the world follows from his
presumption of reason
he thought that his system described the
only logically possible
world
and this is why he could write with such
consummate
confidence
to a young man whom he'd once taught
who had just converted to catholicism
and was now challenging his former
teacher or nameless philosopher
in um admittedly
obnoxious way
exhorting him to save himself from
everlasting damnation etc etc by
accepting jesus as his personal savior
how
this young student this impertinent
young man demanded
can you presume that you have found the
best philosophy
here's what the philosopher wrote back i
do not presume that i have found the
best philosophy
i know that i understand the true
philosophy
if you ask in what way i know it
i answer
in the same way as you know that the
three angles of a triangle
are equal to two right angles
if there are no arbitrary aspects of
reality he argues and there can't be he
asserts on the basis of the presumption
of reason
then logic itself
must logically must explain the world
what he will assert in fact
is that logic itself
is the world
logical entailments are the very stuff
of reality
logic itself is the world because it has
to be logically
if there are to be no dangling
inexplicables
the world itself consists of all logical
implications
spun out in their entirety
only not lying dead and inert
but an infinity of logical implications
that is infinitely aware of itself
animated with thought and taking on the
full heft
and weight of being
this vast and animated system of logical
implications
of logic spun out in its entirety
is what the world must be if all is to
be explained
it's this vast suite of logical
entailments that he famously dubs deus
siwei nattora
god or nature
the world is the thing that can be
conceived of alternatively
as god or as nature
though clearly what he means to signify
by these two common words is something
quite distinct from what we usually mean
to signify by them both god and nature
this claim
about what the world
really is
entails a particular answer as to how we
can come to know the world
or in the language of philosophy and
ptolemy dictates epistemology
if the world is constituted of the stuff
of logic
if all that exists exists necessarily
then there's only one faculty of the
human mind suitable for perceiving the
world as it truly is
and that's the faculty of pure reason
the faculty that grasps logical
connections
there's a perfect fit
between the stuff of reality
and our faculty of reason
or as this philosopher puts it one of my
favorite lines
one that
sings to me of poetry
the eyes of the mind whereby it sees
things and understands are none other
than proofs
this philosopher's ambitions on behalf
of reason
are staggering
pure reason can deduce not only the
nature of the world what it's like its
fundamental laws
but also the reason why it exists at all
it can also deduce pure a priori reason
ethics
the way we ought to live
what we ought to desire and care about
the shape that our lives should take
not only what is can be deduced through
pure reason but what ought to be he
claims
in fact he calls his magnum opus the
work in which he lays out the full far
reaches of his system
the ethics
notice that he's given over to pure
reason the human capacity for seeing
what follows from what
the ability to deduce for itself answers
that are more often claimed to belong to
the domain of religion
such questions as
why does the world exist at all why is
there something rather than nothing
what's the difference between right
living and wrong living between good and
evil what should we want from our lives
what is it to have lived a life well
lived
can we achieve salvation and if so how
the presumption of reason which he
argues entails not only the world as it
is but the world as it had to be
not only the world as it had to be
but our lives as they ought to be
this presumption of reason led him to
deny any
need to resort to the claims
of revelations from on high
or to rely on the clergy's attempt to
mediate between us and on high
reason trumps religion
and he likes this because the danger is
lurking in religious belief
in the excesses of believers there are
ulterior motives
not to speak of the ulterior motives of
religious leaders
was an issue that he felt very keenly
religious intolerance was in fact his
paramount concern
the problem that animated his life and
his work
he was proposing that our faculty of
reason
could combat
the dangers of religious belief
proposing to defang the superstitious
religions
with a religion of reason
that would cancel out render redundant
the conventional religions that had
wielded such power and wreaked such
havoc
on the society of his day
and and ours
were the clergy happy with him
they were not
his religion of reason offered just like
more conventional reasons
the promise of salvation
we can save ourselves he said in the
only way that doesn't entail a lie about
reality
by becoming
rigorously ruthlessly rational
by objectively seeing the world and our
place within it
the world is the all-embracing web of
necessary connections
intelligible through and through
and our own individual personal
salvation
rests in our knowingness
in seeing the world through the eyes of
the mind the proofs of abstract reason
our own personal salvation motivated by
our essential commitment to our own
individual survival and well-being
consists in achieving the most
impersonal of world views
to assimilate this viewpoint is to
achieve a stance of radical objectivity
to see everything including one's own
self
subspeculate
as he put it under the guise of a
certain form of eternity
from this vantage point all the purely
individual facts of one's existence
the circumstances into which one was
passively born
for example one's family and history
one's racial religious cultural sexual
or national identity
all of this these passive markers of our
identity
recede into insignificance
and the lingering emotional attack
attachments to such accidents of
precedence
are only evidence of impartial
rationality and obstacles in the way of
achieving a life worth living
to the extent that we're rational he
argues
merely personal matters
matter not at all
to the extent that we're rational
personal identity itself shrivels away
into insignificance
the fact of who i happen to be in the
infinite scheme of things
a fact which throbs the very special
significance for me
disappears all together in the
apprehension of the scheme itself
this is what i meant by saying that he's
philosophy's strongest advocate of
impersonal detachment
the truly astounding conclusion that he
reached is this
to the extent that we're rational which
is of course what we ought to be
we all of us partake
in the very same identity
when one achieves this purely active
identity this fulfillment of one's
rational capacity that induces a sense
of near estrangement from one's own
passively received self
then
one is saved
one is delivered into a sort of
rationalist bliss
what he called amor day intellectualis
the intellectual love of god
in the grip of this vision
one can regard even one's own personal
demise
the thought one dare not think
with a degree of philosophical
detachment
the wise man he says
thinks least of all things upon his own
death
our inability to realistically
contemplate our own demise accounts
according to this philosopher
for the otherwise
incomprehensible power over us of those
superstitious religions
only reason as rigorous as we can muster
it up can truly save us
both give us the truth
as it really is
and also deliver us from our primal fear
of the truth
this is the state of blessedness toward
which this philosopher's work will
through its severe proofs try to deliver
us
when we have attained an adequate
knowledge of the infinite system which
is the one and only self-explanatory
substance god or nature that infinite
system which consists of a vast sweeping
interlocking matrix of necessary
connections
and by so grasping it transformed our
very selves
purging our own minds of the illusions
of contingency
reconstituting our minds with the divine
necessity
so filling our minds with that absolute
necessity that encompasses everything
including one's own self
that the contingent connection with that
one thing and the vast spread of things
with which one happens to be identical
seems to waver almost out of existence
then and only then peace will be
possible within each of us the peace of
acquiescence
and only peace will be possible among us
the peace of unity of purpose
we will at long last have arrived at the
state of mind dubbed blessedness
by the man who had been known in three
different languages
hebrew portuguese and latin
by a name that translates into blessed
bento
and benedictus
and his last name of course was spinoza
spinoza
benedictus spinoza
the holy fuhrer aroused by the name of
spinoza both in his day he lived in the
18th century he was born in 1632 and and
died at the age of 44 in 1675.
the holy few are aroused by his name in
his own day
and well into the 18th century the age
of enlightenment
is in contrast to the man's predilection
for peace and quiet
he confessed himself to have a horror of
controversy
quote i absolutely dread quarrels he
wrote an acquaintance explaining why he
declined to publish a shorter work that
can seem some of the main themes of the
ethics
were called short treatise on god man
and his well-being and he never did
publish the ethics during his lifetime
it was published posthumously
this signet ring he wore throughout his
life was inscribed with the word kaute
latin for
cautiously
and it was engraved with the image of a
thorny rose so that he signed his name
literally subrosa
one might argue that the very style of
the ethics and if you've taken a look
into its pages you know what i mean
written in the highly formalized
geometrical style inspired by euclid's
elements
that this style is partially designed
for the practical purpose of keeping out
any but the most gifted of readers
rigorously cerebral and patiently
rational
a rationalist extremist
one who made every claim for pure reason
that has ever been made
the power to give us the world as it
really is and all its severe necessity
its necessary severity
and in so giving it to us
to deliver us from the torments of our
own
finitude
and now that i've gone so far as to put
a name to this apostle of impersonal
truth
i'm going to betray spinoza in a far
more serious way
i'm going to ask the sort of question
about him that the philosophical
training in general
and his own philosophy in particular
actively discourages
i'm going to try to figure out something
of the story behind his philosophy
i'm going to be a bit of a novelist
i'm going to ask what it is in his own
particular history
not viewed sub-specky eternitatis but in
all its personal specificity
that might have led him to take so
radical of you in regard to the
questions of identity and salvation
i'm going to try to pro well i'm not
going to try to betray and i'm going to
portray him by trying to place his
vision of radical objectivity in some
sort of historical context
which in the case of spinoza means the
context of jewish history
i think i've said enough about the
vision of spinoza for you to see what an
act of treachery it is that i'm
proposing
to view the man who urged us to achieve
the most impersonal vision of ourselves
throwing off the passive markers of our
identities
so that to the extent that we are
constituted of the stuff of the world
logic we are in all essentials
indistinguishable from one another to
view that
uncompromising advocate of unconstrained
impersonality
so narrowly and so personally
and yet
this is what i proposed to do
to view him as a man born into extreme
circumstances
into a community that was itself
obsessed with intertwined issues of
identity and
salvation into a community that couldn't
help but be obsessed with such issues
because it had endured a centuries-long
crisis of identity of an agonizing life
and death intensity
i'm going to suggest that those extreme
historical circumstances are not
irrelevant to spinoza's extreme
rationalism
spinoza's system
is what one arrives at when one applies
mathematically inspired cartesianism
after the philosopher rene descartes
to the problem of jewish history
the oddness of viewing spinoza as a jew
is highlighted by the fact that there's
a disinclination on the part of many
jews to view spinoza as a jew
his very own community resolutely
renounced him as one
on july 27
1656 we've just celebrated not
celebrated
commemorated uh the 350th anniversary of
course this past summer
the following writ of formal
excommunication
was read out in the portuguese jewish
synagogue of amsterdam before the
gathered congregants the man of the of
the hour not not precisely the guest of
honor
wasn't himself present he skipped the
event
it's a long document it's a fascinating
document and i'll read you just a bit of
it
by decree of the angels and by the
command of the holy men we excommunicate
expel curse and damn barach d espinoza
with the consent of god blessed be he
and with the consent of the entire holy
congregation and in front of these holy
scrolls with the 613 precepts which are
written therein cursing him with the
excommunication with which joshua banned
jericho and with the curse which alicia
cursed the boys and with all the
castigations that are written in the
book of the law
curse be he by day and cursed be he by
night curse be he when he lies down and
curse be he when he rises up
curse be he when he goes out and curse
be he when he comes in
the lord will not spare him but then the
anger of the lord in his jealousy shall
smote against that man and all the
curses that are written in this book
shall lie upon him and the lord shall
blot out his name from under heaven
and the lord shall separate him onto
evil out of all the tribes of israel
according to all the curses of the
covenant that are written in this book
of the law
but you that cleave unto the lord your
god are alive every one of you this day
we warn that none may contact him orally
or in writing nor do him any favor nor
stay under the same roof with him nor
read any papers he made or wrote
i'm going to stop before it gets really
nasty
was then 23 years old
he hadn't yet written any of the works
for which we now know and celebrate him
he had studied in the jewish community
school the talmud torah
most likely under the chief rabbi rabbi
murtera as well as under the two other
very famous rabbis of the community
rabbi boab and menasha ben israel
he had been an outstanding student
no surprise
what had that studious boy done that had
so enraged his community
though the writ of excommunication is
long on column may as you saw it's short
on specific charges
only vague heresies and abominable ways
are vaguely mentioned
the vehemence and finality of his
denunciation has long intrigued scholars
but not because excommunication
which the hebrew word of course is
excommunication
suggests something
a little too strong as i'll show you but
not because harem was rare in the
amsterdam community
quite the contrary
harem was practiced in his community was
not as severe and final a punishment as
the word now suggests maybe ostracism as
a better word for it rather than
excommunication
the period of isolation from the
community the terms of the harem didn't
extend outside of amsterdam
typically lasted anywhere from a day or
two maybe several years if it was a
really serious transgression
one did one's penance and return to the
community
the imposed banishment
very serious to be banished from one's
community when one's a jew it's such a
communal religion
the composed banishment was a
tool of chastisement chastisement
resorted to with quite common frequency
fundamentally a form of public
embarrassment with which to exert
control
over the volatile mix living in
spinoza's jewish community of amsterdam
but the terms of spinoza's harem
precluded his return to the fold forever
and it's this implacability that poses
the mystery of spinoza's excommunication
what i propose is that spinoza had
probed
and prodded the most bruised and tender
spot
in his community's shared psyche
the very issue of identity
it was a community of refugees from the
spanish portuguese inquisition
and this was a jewish calamity whose
tragic proportions would be exceeded
only in the 20th century
the members of the synagogue were
sephardim those who had originally come
from spain so far
farad of course being the hebrew for
uh spain
and they were predominantly former ranos
excuse me those who had lived on the
iberian peninsula mostly in portugal
which is where the bulk of the jews had
gone
after they were expelled from spain
they had lived in portugal as practicing
christians since judaism had been
formally outlawed on the iberian
peninsula at the end of the 15th century
in spain in 1492 and then in portugal in
1497.
the word murano probably derives from
the old castilian for swine
a particularly apt slur to insult those
believed to be concealing jewish
practice beneath christian performance
the proportion of what were called new
christians and this appellation would
stick even after generations of
practicing christianity
the proportion of new christians who
were actually crypto judaizers muranos
is still highly disputed by historians
but what is not in dispute was that the
office of the holy inquisition was
untiringly wary of all new christians
always watching for backsliding into
jewish rites which was punishable by
awful death
everything accusations imprisonment
torture
forced confessions sentencing took place
under the greatest secrecy
contributing to the terror
the flimsiest grounds could serve as an
accusation
for example extreme personal hygiene
could be interpreted as crypto judaism
an old habit from the days before
conversion absent-mindedly reverted to
could cost a person his or her life and
bring catastrophic attention to his or
her extended clan as well
the guidelines that the church issued
for detecting a crypto jew
included such behavior as wearing clean
clothes on saturdays
draining away the blood of meat and
cutting away its fat and gristle
an accused person never got the
opportunity to face his accusers so
personal vendettas as well as envy
malice and greed could serve as motives
an idea from hell
the inquisition was arguably
europe's first experiment with racialist
ideology went on to others
one inquisitor for example wrote in 1628
or soon thereafter a few years before
spinoza's birth quote from the moment of
its conception every fetus permanently
carries with it the moral attributes in
the case of the muranos the moral
depravity of its parents unquote
this wasn't a new idea in portugal the
sermons preached on the occasions of the
otto's defeat which literally means acts
of faith
often stress the theological and moral
immutability of the jews
the rejections of the tenets of
christianity the spurning of jesus as
savior
even those who became prominent within
the church's own hierarchy and many new
christians did
was encoded according to many of the
inquisitors
in the blood in the tainted blood
the former conversos who came to
amsterdam and this community was
predominantly composed of former
conversos
in the first years of the 16th century
brought with them the interwoven
preoccupations with identity and
salvation
that the inquisition had forced on them
the very liberal city especially in its
day 16th century
uh
europe the very liberal city of
amsterdam provided the conditions for
the former new christians of portugal
to reconnect to a judaism that most of
them barely knew they'd all gotten all
mixed up with catholic rights so for
example
the favorite
heroine of the muranos was saint esther
um so from from the purim story at all
which is interesting that she was the
favorite since she of course was a
murano herself she she hid her
jewishness from king achashversh
the psychological atmosphere of the
community was fraught to put it mildly
the dark history that the returning jews
brought with them sought of that
the hopes for the religion that had been
clung to in secrecy turned in some when
they got to amsterdam to fierce
religiosity messianic and mystical
in others it turned to
bitter disappointment
disillusion
attempts to argue with the rabbis as to
what true judaism really ought to be
many of them had learned about judaism
by reading
the five books of moses i didn't know
about the accretion of all those
talmudic laws they didn't like it
a lot of them returned to christianity
this was a community that was unusually
focused on the subject of identity
especially of religious identity
jewish identity of what counts as being
jewish and whether the salvation many of
them considered implicit in their jewish
identity was brought about by outwardly
practicing as jews
in which case their murano brethren back
in iberia weren't really jews
or whether the simple acknowledgement of
oneself as a jew even in the hidden
recesses of one's murano heart
was sufficient for making one jewish
or whether even the self-eval wasn't
necessary whether one's jewishness and
therefore one's salvation was in the
blood so to speak they tended to speak
much of salvation which isn't even
particularly a jewish idea this was part
of the christianity which they had
imbibed
the community of amsterdam was often
rent by terribly painful altercations on
what it means what it is to be jewish
because of their immediate history
because of the conditions under which
their friends and relations back on the
iberian peninsula were still living
these questions of identity always
fraught for jews i think but for them
were thought out and lived out with
terrible urgency
how would an exquisitely sensitive soul
such as spinoza
and to read and study the ethics is to
know how acutely
psychologically attentive he was
how would he have reacted to this hum of
impassioned obsession with these
questions about jewish identity and
personal salvation
the omnipresence of a seemingly
irresolvable dilemma that was charged
with so much ongoing anxiety
and terrible suffering
like the lover of mathematics that he
was
he would try to seek a clear and
definitive solution
the deepest sort of solution
the sort that reframes the original
question entirely that in fact makes the
original question altogether disappear
his solution would be to dissolve and
it's really the first man of modern age
to propose this
dissolve all sectarian frames of
reference
to become in effect the first secularist
but even more strenuously to point the
way to a concept of personal identity in
which this fraught question of who is
jewish and who is not
simply could not meaningfully arise
it becomes a question of no account at
all when life is viewed subspecial
eternitatis
spinoza becomes the first jew of the
modern age who attempts not only to
think
but to live outside the definition of
himself as jewish
or as christian
he didn't convert to christianity
although it would have been highly
convenient for him to do so
he renounced any religious identity
whatsoever wouldn't allow any religious
identity to define him
a radical idea in the 17th century
growing up in an atmosphere in which the
question of personal identity throbbed
with all the cumulative tragedy of the
sephardic experience
he would be the philosopher who would
radically rethink the very notion of
personal identity itself
spinoza i think had somehow indicated to
his community
years before he had yet worked out the
details of his system that would set
forth his own way of connecting identity
and salvation
he had indicated
that their issues of identity weren't
his
and this was the one offense that going
so deeply against the tried faith of
these recovering muranos
couldn't be forgiven
it's not accidental that his response to
the harem is to change his name his
identity from barach to benedictus
he went about trying to shed as
inessential
all the passive markers of who he was
the accidents of his identity come to
him by way of his history
jewish history
instead identifying himself only in
terms of what he was
in relation to the infinite system which
is reality
and of course what he was in relation to
that infinite system
is precisely the same as that which any
of us is in relation to the infinite
system
the only way we differ from one another
he said
is the degree to which we know that
infinite system
and this is a difference that can be
eradicated through rational thought
assimilating the objective necessity of
daisy natora
into the thinking matter of ourselves
it was the community itself that had
made the problem of personal identity
of such crushing exigency for spinoza
that a way had to be found out of it
even though the way would set him at
irreconcilable odds with that community
but the history of suffering a living
palpable history with conversos arriving
every day and new incidents of the
inquisition's avenging power taking
place throughout spinoza's life and way
beyond
together
with all the psychological devastation
that had been
wrought posed the initial problem
for which
the severity and the grandeur
of spinoza's conceptual system
is the answer
sanguine cartesian rationalism somewhat
chill and temperament
becomes in the system of this son of
muranos
a solution to the
horrors of jewish suffering
that some of his surviving letters show
us he never ceased to respond to in a
way that we might call
despite the rationalists
best attempts
a jewish sensibility
for his particular community however
seeking its jewish identity with such
historical passion
spinoza's solution was the most damnable
betrayal that one of their own could
commit
it was to deny
that he was one of their own
it was to deny meaning to that very
phrase
one of our own
the final vision of reality
that boroch spinoza benedictus spinoza
arrived at is so dauntingly universal
so large and impersonal
that it's strange to contemplate
that perhaps the original psychological
drama that pointed him on the path that
was to take him so far away from his
community
was to try to think himself outside of
the dilemmas of jewish identity
dilemmas that are no less provocative
today
no less difficult for many of us to
resolve
today than they were for him and that
that philosophical extremists
went and offered the most excre extreme
solution
uh that's ever been offered to us
to the dilemmas of being a jew
thank you
[Applause]
yes and so um you're asked to speak into
the microphone if you might
i have two questions
i read an article in commentary
many many years ago
saying that
the reason behind spinoza's
excommunication was political that the
jewish community had to represent
themselves to the dutch community as a
particular
set of beliefs and and formal actions
and that uh espinoza speaking this way
brought into
uh
doubt what the jewish community was and
this was very threatening and the second
one was what did it mean when einstein
uh referred said that his god was
spinoza's god okay thank you
um yes there are many um
the terms of the harem are
so
are so extreme that scholars have have
wondered about this harem was quite
common as i as i indicated and there
have been other heretics others who had
who had been uh who'd question some of
the basic tenets and had been put in
harem and had been allowed in um so
there is it is certainly true um that
the jews uh in amsterdam lived with some
anxiety about their their dutch hosts
in fact when they were given permission
uh they first came in secret um and to
at the end of the 16th century um
and actually one of the legends is that
somebody heard a neighbor heard some
strange chanting friday night and
thought uh they were papist thought it
was latin um and brought in the
authorities and it turned out to be
hebrew um and they were slowly given
permission uh first to build a cemetery
then to
build a synagogue it wasn't um automatic
and they had been made uh to promise
that they would keep control over their
own community
um and that and that their
uh
the the jews already that community
already had a reputation um as harboring
free thinkers and heretics it was a
community fraud you know filled with
questions um and they were supposed to
keep uh control so there is def that
definitely has to be taken into account
uh the fact that they were nervous about
the their uh the calvinists in
particular were not so very thrilled
about having the jews in their midst so
it was there was this tension
when i say that it was europe's most
liberal
city uh of the 17th century it's the
17th century
so
that definitely there is also but that
doesn't seem to explain it enough
because there had been others uh joseph
de prada was uh excommunicated at the
same time um espinoza the terms are not
that severe um or
arielle decosta was excommunicated twice
and he was a terrible heretic right he
wasn't but they let him um come back in
and then he was excommunicated again and
they let him come back in again
um and why why so severe these other
api corsam heretics
were
they wanted back in they still
identified with that community spinoza
that had indicated he didn't when he was
excommunicated he's reported to have
said so much the better i wouldn't have
had the courage to do it for myself but
they make it easy for me now i go my own
way
um he had already started studying latin
with a defrocked priest franciscus
vanden enden a
curious fascinating guy who believed in
free love and all sorts of interesting
things but he spinoza was studying uh
latin which of course was the lingua
franca of that day he wrote in latin
that was the language that that all
scholars wrote in he
his eyes were pointing outside of the
community one other thing that he did
which also was a might have had a lot to
do with his indicating his
his uh his distance from the community
um was there was a lawsuit this
always comes down to money and he uh he
was in fact in a lawsuit over money with
his sister rebecca and uh her husband
was one of the
favorite pupils of
the chief rabbi and spinoza knew he
didn't have a chance with the
jewish beit din he went court of law he
went to the civil court of law a
terrible offense to the community again
indicating his
independence his lack of identification
so i think
although this is very true the anxiety
of this very nervous traumatized group
of people um
and
their nervousness vis-a-vis the
calvinist authorities has to be taken
into account um there's more to this
story in the case of spinoza einstein
einstein whenever einstein was asked a
philosophical question what is his
beliefs about the nature of the world he
always described himself
as a spinozist
um and it's uh you know in his more
philosophical writings he always talks
about spinoza that he's a spinozist um
he um
he was very interested in the idea that
lies at the core of spinoza's
uh system
that the laws of nature
if we have the final view of the laws of
nature will understand why they had to
be the laws of nature that that unified
field theory will not only describe the
laws of nature but
why they were they
they are why they were realized uh one
of the ways he puts this is did god have
any choice in the matter um this is a
very spinozistic idea god did not you
know it's logic that dictates it also
einstein writes very very beautifully
about having lost the early religious
paradise of his youth and his science
having taken the place of it and he says
when he regards the
the laws of nature and all their
beauty
um there's a kind of awe there's a kind
of love that comes over one uh that
that's a
sort of religious
certainly spiritual um
um and and once again this is the
intellectual love of god that that he's
that he's describing here so i think in
both of these aspects uh he he was a
spinoza his son-in-law actually had
written a uh um
biography of spinoza and uh so he you
know he knew he knew much about there's
also i think i have it um
reproduced in my
um
in betraying spinoza in the book um
on the guest page of spinoza's um house
that you can visit um there's there's
einstein's signature he actually went um
made a pilgrimage um as did i uh to uh
to spinoz spinoza's uh
home
yes
oh i'm sorry and then
about a year or two ago uh there was a
um
uh mr portuguese named uh
meta medic medical uh scientist who
wrote a book uh with the title spinoza
in it and where the big finding was a
scientific finding and a result of which
a kind of an interest and renewal
into spinoza irrespective of his
philosophy where apparently spinoza
intuited that
the the emotionalism
and more or less sentimentalism precedes
rationalism
and apparently they make a big deal
because experimentally they found from
their clinical work that this is so
and apparently they give great credit to
spinoza for having intuited this notion
would you please expand
so the name of the writer is antonio
dimazio
um and he is indeed portuguese
and um and the book was called uh
looking for spinoza or something like
that yes
um
and um
you'll notice that i have a blurb from
tonio de matia on the back cover
yes
uh dimazio is a
neurologist um and claims that spinoza
um presciently
foresaw a great
the latest findings in neurology
spinoza
followed descartes their lives overlap a
little he was influenced by descartes
although he takes rationalism much
farther
descartes had famously said that the
mind and the body are two separate
things
spinoza says they're not it's one thing
everything that happens in our mind our
everything in our minds our emotions our
thinking all of this is embodied there's
always something going on in the body as
well
when we change our minds we're changing
our bodies as well
so he was what we call an identity
theorist dimazio applauds him for this
this is you know certainly
contemporary
neurology tends to go in this direction
also spinoza had said
and this is a key and spinoza's ethics
is not only this work that tries to tell
us what reality is like it's a how-to
book uh how to save your own life really
how to save yourself how to go about
changing yourself um
changing your emotions spinoza believed
that we really rationally can when we
understand the nature of reality and
ourselves in relation to that reality we
can
reconstruct ourselves our emotions uh
what we care about in fact all painful
emotions can be excised i mean if you if
you believe that everything is necessary
what's the point of remorse and anger
envy jealousy all those nasty emotions
if everything is necessary so we can
actually
reconstruct our emotional responses and
a great deal of the ethics tries to
tell you how to do this so this
blessedness he also says is a state of
sustained happiness
what dimazio also loves about spinoza is
that spinoza believed that there wasn't
such a separation between thinking and
feeling the emotions contain a cognitive
elements the emotions
contain entail a judgment about the way
the world is affecting me
so all at the heart of all emotions
spinoza uh claims is my commitment to
myself i want to prosper in my life to
flourish to to expand in the world
why because i'm me there's just no way
around it that's what it is to be
oneself you are committed to oneself is
there any reason for it no that's that's
who you are
um
all of my emotions contain some sense of
my either flourishing or it's the
opposite contracting in the world plus a
judgment about how the world is causing
this so there's always this judgmental
aspect to the emotions
emotions aren't just
gut wrenching or exhilarating feelings
they're tied up with our cognition and
therefore can be changed so many of them
contain false judgments about the world
that is also the aspect
that
dimazio applauds that there's really not
a separation between cognition and the
emotions that they're intertwined with
one another and that's why he
he says that uh that he's a spinozist as
well
um it was very interesting for a man who
got the scientific method all wrong
spinoza did because he thought
everything was a priori through pure
reason uh he really downplays empirical
findings
um it's very interesting how much he
seemed to get right uh and i mean there
are string there are many string
theorists who are spinozas who believe
that spinoza sort of had their the basic
outlook um and then here's dimazio
saying in neurology um that spinoza's
ideas have been vindicated so it's it's
interesting and it's mysterious to me
because his method was all wrong yes
yes
i'd like you to comment on
uh spinoza's belief in an absolute
rationality in the light of a girdle
girdles
proof that
no logical system is complete so
i know you've written a book about
girdle so you've thought
so
yes so the question is
kurt girdle
in
1931 published a very famous proof the
incompleteness theorems
um there are actually two
and uh it was a one of the most
important results in mathematical logic
probably the most important result of
mathematical that no formal system
that's consistent
that can't produce any contradictions
is complete for a formal system of logic
it's either inconsistent or it's
incomplete what is incomplete mean means
that there are certain truths that are
expressible in that system but you can't
prove in that system so not everything
can be proved um and that's what
what girdle proved right that that no
system
what he produced
amazingly
was
a proposition
that we can see is true by getting out
of the system but that can't be proved
in the system and
for each system you can produce such a
proposition that we can see is true but
it can't be derived in that system
so
um spinoza
so girdle first of all is talking when
he's talking about formal systems he
means something very narrow he's talking
about formal systems as a logician talks
about that term
and what he was saying basically is that
mathematics can't be reduced to logic
mathematics is something more than pure
logic
spinoza's use of the word logic is much
wider uh than girdles
it's it's not as precise it's not as
strict he's not using the word logic as
a logician uses it when he's talking
about formal systems which is a very
technical narrow notion so i don't think
that girdle's
uh proof touches spinoza here's another
thing
goodell's
result has to do with what we can prove
and he says there's a limitation on what
we can prove not even what we can know
we can know more according to girdle
than what we can prove than what we can
formally prove we see that this is true
but we can't prove it
um
spinoza recognized he had to
that not
we can't prove everything
in fact he says we can't even know
everything we're finite
we're our minds are finite they consist
of even in when they're the most
rational and let's say i've purged
everything but
logical necessity it's only going to be
some finite num amount of logical
necessity what reality is is infinite it
consists of
the entire
web of logical connections spun out in
their entirety we can't know it all
so spinoza himself
acknowledges a certain incompleteness to
to our knowledge
we can know enough to know to save
ourselves to to achieve a kind of
acquiescence and tranquility but we
certainly
it to see everything uh would be to have
the mind of god and that we can't we're
we're finite god is infinite but we can
reconcile ourselves to our our our
fineitude so i think it's okay i think
my two favorite guys are um consistent
with each other
oh
okay right after
you commented on the historical
you commented on the historical context
which helped shape spinoza
what do we know about the personal
context that might have influenced
his beliefs
yeah
did he have a family
he had a family
[Laughter]
everybody has a family well
right um
one of the things i write about it in
the book that i first learned about
spinoza when i was uh
yeshiva girl in a very very right-wing
orthodox yeshiva learned about him in my
class in jewish history in very
not very flattering terms
and um
the thing that
got me that pierced me through and
through was that my historia teacher had
mentioned that spinoza abby korres that
heretic that he was
um
didn't reveal his difference his his his
heresy until after his parents had died
um and he his mother died when he was a
child he was brought up uh i think when
he was eight his father remarried um
they had very bad lungs uh his mother
died of tuberculosis his older brother
died of tuberculosis spinoza died of
tuberculosis probably exacerbated uh by
the dust of oh i didn't tell you he
supported himself
by grinding lenses for telescopes and
other scientific instruments uh huygens
the great astronomer would only use the
lenses ground by he called him he never
actually called him by name our jew
of rohrberg it's after the
excommunication
but
he
in fact set shiva for his father he went
through the entire year of mourning we
can actually see the charitable
donations he gave he kept up with the
charitable donations that were set by
the community
and until
after his father had died and so
there is this as my historia teacher had
put it uh it was because of shalom bias
right peace peace in the house that he
respected that and i
that you know even as this ignorant
little girl that i was
um
that intrigued me so much that this this
heretic
um had uh
had honored his parents in that in that
way it touched me very deeply who was
herself beginning to have extreme doubts
about it all
and worried about her family and
upsetting her family so
there was this um
there was this uh attitude towards his
family
we don't know so much about him um there
are there are some
uh
legends about a woman um he was he never
married um
and
um
he has if you read uh the the ethics or
or read my book where i sum it up
he has a
very
sour views about romantic love
and romantic love always ends badly
according to him
and
so this can get a novelist mind going
but we really don't know all that much
about he left some he left letters um he
had after he was excommunicated the jews
couldn't
converse with him he had been in
business with his younger brother
gabriel the family business his father
had been an import expert
and he had inherited the business but as
after that his brother didn't talk to
him nobody in the family did and so he
went into
the lens grinding business to support
himself
and
he um
mostly
um he he really lived a very quiet
secluded life most of the people he were
was in contact with were kind of fringe
protestants quakers
mennonites
not not those not calvinists but uh
but but sort of reminiscents
these were there were about six or seven
or eight
uh
young men who considered spinoza their
master and we have um letters between
them and so some of our uh knowledge of
his life comes from that but very little
because they were edited
by his friends who also published the
ethics a year after his death
and almost everything of a personal
nature was stricken
so
you know he preached in personality and
he certainly comes across when you read
these letters as very impersonal as
uncompromisingly high-minded but of
course these edit these letters had been
severely edited
so there's not all that much
that's been known but a lot a lot
can be
imagined and of course that's one of the
things i try to do thank you
[Applause]
this event was hosted by next book an
organization that promotes jewish
literature and ideas for more
information on baruch spinoza and author
rebecca goldstein visit nextbook.org
[Music]